past a certain level of complexity
every system starts looking like a
living
organism in order to build a general
intelligence
you need to be optimizing for generality
itself
we are surrounded by isomorphisms
just like a kaleidoscope it creates a
remarkable richness of patterns from a
tiny little bit of information
generalization is the ability to mine
previous experience to make sense of
future
novel situations generalization
describes a knowledge differential
it characterizes the ratio between known
information and the space of possible
future situations
to what extent can we analogize the
knowledge
that we already have into simulacrums
that apply
widely across experienced space
so intelligence which is to say
generalization power
is literally sensitivity to abstract
analysis
and that's in fact all there is to it in
today's show we are joined by francois
charles
i have been using the keras library for
many years
i also read his deep learning with
python book which was inspiring
and i discovered his racy twitter feed
when i worked for microsoft i used to
run machine learning seminars and
workshops and hackathons
i used to travel around the world and i
always had a copy
of francoise book under my arm it never
left my side
i used to force everyone to read the
first four chapters of that book and of
course the chapter
on the limitations of deep learning
before we did anything
francois has a clarity of thought
which is unparalleled i think in any
other human being on the planet
it's really quite incredible indeed even
our own
dr duggar who normally has
no trouble at all finding holes in some
of our guests work
had this to say while prepping for the
show
i am working on it it turned out to be a
little bit more difficult than i thought
charlay is a little bit too reasonable
yeah do you like my dagger accent
he would enjoy me doing that but anyway
charlay is extremely controversial to
some people actually
but he's not controversial to us our
discussion today lies at the
intersection
of machine learning and reasoning now
chalet has made his vision
completely clear about what he thinks
the future of machine learning is
make no mistake what you should take
from today's episode
is that the future of artificial
intelligence is going to be discreet
as well as continuous actually the two
are going to be
enmeshed the future of ai will almost
certainly involve
a large degree of program synthesis
deep learning has its limits you can use
deep learning for continuous problems
where the data is interpolative and has
a learnable manifold
and where you have a dense sampling
across the entire surface
of the manifold between which you need
to make predictions
for chalet generalization itself is by
far the most
important feature of intelligence and of
developing
strong ai he describes a spectrum of
generalization
starting with for example a chess
algorithm
where there is no novelty to adapt to
whatsoever
the task is fixed the machine learning
we have today
confers some adaptation within a known
domain
of tasks for example being able to
recognize
dogs or cats within a variety of
different poses and lighting conditions
what's not been robustly demonstrated so
far
is broad generalization adaptation to
unknown unknowns within a known but
broad
domain it's certainly true that we're
knocking on the door of this now with
gbt3 where
the subtask if you like is given at test
time
although charley would make the argument
that the sub-task isn't learned at test
time
everything that gbt3 knows was learned
on the vast amounts of training data
that we trained it on
the poet algorithm from kenneth stanley
that appears to be meta learning tasks
as part of the training process which is
very very interesting so it's creating
new problems and new solutions as part
of the training process
but broadly speaking in the machine
learning space at the moment
the task that we are doing is fixed and
not generalizable the other thing is
that the real world does not have a
static distribution
we need systems that can adapt
dynamically
intelligence requires that you adapt to
novelty without
the help of the engineer who helped you
write the system
chalet has come up with a formalism of
intelligence that balances
the task skill the difficulty the
knowledge
and experience to effectively quantify
and normalize
an algorithmic information conversion
ratio
it's the ability to convert experience
into future skill
that is chalet's measure of intelligence
at the end of his measure of
intelligence paper francois introduced
the arc challenge
it became a kaggle competition as well
and it introduced a massive
diversity of tasks the reason we have a
diversity of tasks
is for developer aware generalization
any
model that we have needs to generalize
to tasks that the developer was unaware
of
and charlay thinks that intelligence is
specialized
it needs to be human-centric or
anthropocentric
so the kind of priors that you need to
solve these intelligence tasks
need to represent the kind of prize that
us humans have
now machine learning algorithms are
completely ineffective against the arc
challenge
because it's so challenging to
generalize from a few examples
the only solutions that were effective
in the arc challenge
were program synthesis the manifold
hypothesis
is that natural data forms lower
dimensional manifolds
in its embedding space there are both
theoretical
and experimental reasons to believe this
is true
if you believe this then the task of a
classification algorithm
is fundamentally to separate a bunch of
tangled manifolds
the only way deep learning models can
generalize is
via interpolation most perception
problems in particular
according to francois are interpretive
neural networks
not only have to represent the manifold
of the data that they're learning
the manifold also needs to be learnable
and that's an even tougher constraint
gradient descent will not learn data
that has challenging discontinuities in
its manifold
it'll just resort to memorizing the data
deep learning allows you to represent
complex programs that you couldn't write
by hand
but on the other side of the coin it
also fails to represent very simple
programs
that you could write by hand discrete
so there are some problems where deep
learning is a great fit
and there are other problems where deep
learning is a disaster
and the reason for that is that they are
not interpolative in nature
these tend to be algorithmic reasoning
problems francois thinks that 99
of software written today with code is
not interpolative in nature and
therefore it's a bad fit for deep
learning
the only answer to these problems is
discrete program search
to use deep learning for these problems
requires a lot of data
it's hard to train and the
representation will be glitchy
it'll be brittle neural networks cannot
even extrapolate
the scalar identity function f of x
equals x
they can only interpolate given the
existence of a smooth
manifold in the latent space jan lacoon
recently said to alfredo
that all high dimensional machine
learning is extrapolation
so is this similar to interpolation well
i mean all of machine learning is
similar to interpolation if you want
right
when you train a linear regression on
scalar values you're training a model
right
you're giving a bunch of pairs x and y
you're asking what are the best values
of a and b for y equals ax plus b that
minimizes
the squared error of the prediction of a
line to all of the points right that's
linear regression
that's interpolation all of machine
learning is interpolation in a high
dimensional space
there is essentially no such thing as
interpolation everything is
extrapolation so imagine you are in
in a space of images right so you have a
color images 256 by 256
so 200 000 dimensional input space even
if you have a million samples
you're only covering a tiny portion of
the dimensions
of that space right those images are in
a tiny sliver of
of surface among the the space of all
possible
combinations of values of pixels and so
when you show
the system a new image it's very
unlikely that this image is a linear
combination of previous images what
you're doing is
extrapolation not interpolation okay and
then how did you mention
all of machine learning is extrapolation
which is why it's hard i'm being brave
calling out yan lacoon
the godfather of deep learning but hear
me out
it's certainly true that interpolation
on the native data domain
is useless right we need to pull some
useful information
out of the data and the model
architecture and training method matter
a lot here
we can all agree that interpolation on
the learned manifold
would seem like extrapolation in the
original space of the data
right chalet is quite clear that neural
networks only
generalize through interpolation you
might argue that you can go a tiny step
outside of the convex hull of your data
even by a tiny little bit
and you can technically extrapolate well
i would argue that
if the manifold doesn't give you any
useful information outside of the
training range then it wouldn't be any
better than finding your nearest
training example and just adding a bit
of random noise
if you train again for example you can
interpolate on the latent manifold
but interestingly you can extrapolate
but the reason for that
is the natural manifold that the data of
faces sits on
might be shaped like a football or a
sphere
which means if you go outside of the
training range you actually have
some information about those data points
the scalar identity function might seem
like a contrived example but it's a
really interesting one
when you go outside of the training
range nothing
about the manifold is known right think
about the manifold
it's just a string that goes on forever
we don't know
anything about that manifold outside of
the training range
this is not true for most perceptual
problems and deep learning
and this is why image models for example
suffer greatly drawing straight lines
what are your thoughts about this why
don't you let us know in the comments
section on youtube
so there's a real interesting dichotomy
of continuous problems versus discrete
problems that we're going to be
exploring
in the show today it's very interesting
that brittleness
works both ways depending on the
discreteness of the problem
program synthesis would be extremely
brittle in classifying
cats versus dogs or even mnist
and deep learning would be extremely
brittle predicting the digits of pi
or prime numbers or sorting a list
so britton is here means the overall fit
of your model or your program
so accuracy and robustness imagine if
every single bug you experienced with
computer software
was entirely unique to you and the
development team
wouldn't even be able to reproduce it
this is what would happen if
software was written entirely with
neural networks it would be
more not less brittle chalet thinks that
motivated thinking is the primary
obstacle
to getting people to wake up to the fact
that neural networks
are poorly suited to discrete problems
the people who are good enough at deep
learning
to realize its limitations are too
invested in its success
to say so charles fundamentally thinks
that there are two types of thinking
type one and type two he thinks that
every single thought in our minds
is not simply one or the other rather
it's a combination of both types type
one
and type two they are enmeshed together
in everything you think and in
everything you do
even our reasoning is guided by
intuition which is
interpolative in nature chalet thinks
that abstraction
is key to generalization and the way we
perform
abstraction is different in continuous
versus discrete space we need to find
analogies and those analogies will be
found differently in both of those
different spaces
program search allows us to generalize
broadly
from just a few examples it marks a
significant deviation from traditional
machine learning
rather than trying to interpolate
between the examples you have
you're constructing an entire search
space from scratch
and testing if it fits our training data
it all started with the flash fill
feature in microsoft excel
do you remember that you give a few
examples of some transformation that you
want to perform
and it will generate a piece of
programming code for you
which means it can generalize that
transformation across an entire
spreadsheet
it's quite a revolutionary idea it's
been around for about 20 years actually
but
what's really making it work now is the
idea of using neural networks or a
neural engine
to guide the discrete program search we
spoke about gpt3
he thinks that gpt3 hasn't expanded his
knowledge of the world
he says that gbt3 is not learning any
new algorithms on the fly
it's already learned continuous and
often
glitchy representations of existing
tasks during its training
it's completely ineffective against his
arc challenge tasks
people often claim that neural networks
are turing complete
no they're not a model has
a bounded number of nodes and a bounded
run time
it cannot execute algorithms that
require unbounded space
or unbounded time for example could you
train a neural network
to predict the nth digit of pi no you
couldn't
you could write a computer program to do
it but you couldn't train a neural
network to do it
a simple turing machine program can do
just that and that is because a turing
machine
can access unbounded memory and time the
best thing that neural networks can do
is approximate
unbounded algorithms but doing so will
introduce
glitches for example one can train a
neural network to approximately multiply
integers together yet even when learning
to multiply
fixed-width integers practically sized
neural networks introduce errors
occasionally
and for a fixed size neural network
these errors grow more common
as the size of the input grows that said
neural networks are finite state
machines
and just as finite state machines can be
augmented with unbounded memory
and iteration to yield a turing machine
neural networks can also be automated in
the same way
to produce a touring complete
computational model
if you want to see a concrete example of
the kind of discrete program
search that charlay is talking about
look no further
than the recent dream code of paper
yannick just made a video about it
so yeah it feels like today is the
culmination of a year of really hard
work and passion
from the mlst team we've worked with so
many fascinating people we've had so
many amazing guests on
it really means a lot to us today is a
very very special episode it was my
dream from the beginning to get chalet
on on the show
i know that charles is going to say lots
of interesting things that will trigger
some people and inspire others
and please take to the comments section
and tell us exactly what you think
anyway enjoy the show see you next week
peace out welcome back to the machine
learning street talk youtube channel and
podcast
with my two compadres mit phd dr keith
duggar
and yannick lightspeed culture
now today we have a very special guest
francois charley francois is one of the
few leaders in the machine learning
space
who's caused a massive stir in my
thinking the only other notable one
actually being kenneth stanley
who we had on recently my ultimate goal
with street talk was always to get
francois on the show and i can't believe
that it's actually happened we actually
have a rule by the way that i'm only
allowed to invoke francoise name about
once per show
but that rule will not apply today so
yeah yannick and i have made more
content on francois
chalet actually than anyone else by a
wide margin it's because his work is
very
thought-provoking and disruptive i spent
many weeks actually studying his measure
of intelligence paper last year
and of course his recent europe's
workshop was fascinating as well
almost every single word in my opinion
that comes out of francoise mouth
deserves rigorous study and i seriously
mean that so um francois thinks that
intelligence is embodied
it's a process and it's not just a brain
he's skeptical of the so-called
intelligence explosion
and he thinks there's no such thing as
general intelligence
all intelligence is specialized
critically he thinks that generalization
the ability to deal with novelty and
uncertainty
is the most important concept in
intelligence
he thinks that task specific skills
tells you
nothing about intelligence he thinks
that deep learning only works for
problems where the manifold hypothesis
applies for example problems which are
interpolative
in nature and when a sufficiently dense
sampling of your distribution is
obtained
otherwise deep learning cannot
generalize
deep learning can only memorize but it
cannot
always generalize and in his recent
europe's presentation he introduced the
concept of program-centric and
value-centric generalization
which we'll get into in the show today
but i wanted to move straight on to this
concept
of deep learning being kind of like a
hash table because this is what francois
thinks so he says that a deep learning
model
is kind of like a high dimensional curve
with some constraints on its structure
given by inductive priors and that curve
has enough parameters
that it could fit almost anything right
so if you train your model for long
enough
it will simply memorize your data and
because of sgd your manifold
fit is found progressively and at some
point the manifold will approximate the
natural manifold
between underfitting and overfitting and
at this point you'll be able to make
sense of novel inputs by interpolating
on that manifold so the power of the
model
to generalize is actually a consequence
of the structure of the data
and the gradual process of sgd according
to francois
rather than any property of the model
itself last week francois we were
talking to
christian sergey and he takes a rather
different view because one school of
thought is that deep learning models are
kind of like
searching for a space of possible
programs and advocates of gpt3 make this
argument quite strongly
and presumably christian sergei he
wouldn't be doing what he's doing which
is
interpolating between mathematical
conjectures assuming that
interpolation space would actually give
us new information about mathematics
if he thought that that space wasn't
interpolatable
what do you think francois right i think
you've beautifully summarized it
really yes so interpolation is the
origin
of generalization in deep learning
models and that's very much
by construction by nature right like a
deep learning model
is a very large differentiable
biometric model trained with gradient
descent and so the only way
it's ever going to be generalizing is
your interpolation it is literally
it is this is what it is this is what it
does so i think the question you know
um are all deep learning models
interpreters or not
is not a super interesting question
because it's not an open question we
know they are but the more interesting
question i think is
what can you actually achieve with the
sort of
interpolation on this very complex high
dimensional manifold
and the deep learning models are
implementing i will tell you know the
properties
of this generalization with the the
tasks for which it will perform well the
torso which will not perform violence i
guess one example i could i could give
you
is encoding data with the fourier
transform
right you know about the fourier
transform and maybe you know some people
will
play around with it and they will be
like hey you know actually the fourier
transform can
can draw much more than curves look i
made a square with it
right and then you would have to point
out that no actually the square you've
made it by superposing lots of tiny
curves
and it's not in fact a perfect square
right because it is made of
with the superposition of class of time
curves
and that really this is true by nature
by construction this is where the
fourier transform starts
right and the re the more interesting
question is you know
what sort of data uh is a good fit for
encoding the free transform and with
solar data is not
a good fit like if you try to encode the
t-square fraction
with the fret transform you can have bad
time and if you try to include a drawing
that's
mostly just you know nice uh smooth
curves then
it's going to be a very very efficient
encoding and a good idea and deep
learning is very much like that we
should ask you know what are
strong points whether it's weak points
yeah so i i by the way so i don't
believe
that deep learning models are hashtables
per se i usually say they're
localities a sensitive hashtables
meaning that it can like a hash table
with some amount of generalization power
because they have some notion
of distance between points they're
capable of comparing points
by um measuring the distance between
them right and this this is what would
enable at this kind of hash table to
actually generalize as opposed to the
classic kind of hash table which is just
memorizing the data it's very
interesting that you allude to the fact
that
you know what kind of data is the model
good for and so on and now
deep learning models being essentially
like really
as as tim said like big interpolators of
arbitrary manifolds do you think there
is something
common across the types of data we
choose deep learning for
or you know could we in fact use deep
learning for
most kinds of manifold dish data
or do you think there is some kind of
specialness about natural signals that
makes
deep learning very attune to them
so i think most things are to some
extent
interpolative which is why you can
actually do lots of things with deep
learning marbles doesn't necessarily
mean it's always a good idea
but it's it's gonna kind of work right
you know when people hear the word
interpolation they tend to think about
linear interpolation that's what uh pops
up uh in their mind
that's not actually i already play moles
are doing right they are interpolating
on this very complex
very high dimensional uh manifold and
this enables very
you know arbitrarily complex behavior
and
in practice it's always possible to an
arbitrary a discrete algorithm
in a continuous manifold right it's not
necessarily a good idea but it's always
possible at least in theory so for any
program
you can imagine you can ask you know is
there a deep learning model that will
encode some kind of approximation
of it and the answer is always yes right
uh similar to how you can always
encode an arbitrary shape with the
fourier transform
right but there are if you try to do
that actually there are some issues with
that so
they are very much you know some
problems for which chiptune is good fit
some problem solving deep learning
is not a good fit in the limit the
extreme point
is a space that is not interpolative at
all which is quite rare actually you
know most spaces even very discrete kind
of spaces
do have you know some amounts of
interpretativeness
um so like but one example would be for
instance
trying to train a deep learning model to
predict
uh the next prime number right or or to
tell whether a number is a prime number
but you cannot actually do that the best
you can do is
memorize the trained data upon because
the space of prime numbers
is not uh interpolated at all
so your deep training model will always
have zero generalization power
but that's that's actually quite a quite
rare this kind of an extreme case
most problems even problems that are by
nature discrete
algorithmic problems there will be some
amount of interpolation that you can do
right
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's a good idea to try to to solve you
know
such problems with deep learning models
for deep learning to be a good idea you
need a very
you need very much the manifold
hypothesis to apply
so it works best for perception problems
any problem that humans can solve via
pure intuition
or perception is probably a good fit for
the plan but any problem
where you need you know high level
explicit step-by-step reasoning
is probably a bad fit for the plan and
you know 99
of what today software engineers solve
they are writing code
is going to be a bad fit for the planet
that doesn't mean that there wouldn't be
you know theoretically a deep learning
model
that can embed the same algorithm in
a smooth manifold this is always
possible to some extent right but there
are
very significant issues with attempting
to do this
like just because something is
theoretically possible doesn't mean
you should actually do it i think we
might be
not being careful enough when we say
what we mean by
program because um for example if i take
program to be the the universal sense
like a program is something that can run
on a turing machine for example
because of the fact that that type of
program actually has access to
unbounded time and memory computation
it's impossible in the general sense to
encode that in
any finite neural network like i can
write a very short
piece of code theoretical turing machine
can output you know the nth digit of pi
it's impossible to do that with any
finite neural network would you agree
yeah absolutely
absolutely okay because i think that's
like a big source of confusion
oftentimes with these statements that
like you know
oh neural networks are turing complete
well no they're not that
you know if you have a neural turing
machine which is a neural network that's
the finite state machine
piece of a turing machine that can be
turing complete but in the general case
you know finite neural networks which is
what everyone means by neural networks
are not turning complete and it actually
has practical effects right this is why
we see this sort of
explosion and the number of parameters
to kind of
you know start to accomplish yeah
absolutely 100 your entirely right
so we're only interested in realistic
programs like the sort of programs the
software engineer would write for
instance
and we're only interested in realistic
neural networks and by the way
the constraints that we have on your
networks are actually much stronger than
asking
given this program that i have is there
a neural network that could
embed it in a continuous manifold the
constraint is actually is there a neural
network that
that could not only represent it but
that could learn
this embedding on the program from there
and this is
a several orders of magnitude harder
right learnability is a big problem
because you're fitting
your manifold gradient descent right and
if the if the structure you're trying to
fit is too discrete with two big
discontinuities qualium descent will not
work at all and the best you can do is
again
just memorize the trend there so
i can maybe give you a concrete example
to
kind of ground our discussion here um so
in
2015 some some friend of mine so his
name is he used keras
to do something pretty cool which
actually became a cool example on the
chaos website
he used a lstm model to multiply
numbers but not like numbers multiplied
by value
but the input of the model would be
strings like two strings
strings of digits and the lstm will
actually learn
the multiplication algorithm for like
multiplying three digits and three digit
numbers
kind of the the sort of algorithm we
would learn in primary school right
to do multiplication and remarkably
that worked right it works just fine so
you can train a deep learning model to
learn this algorithm and you could of
course train the transformer model to do
the same it would actually be probably
significantly more efficient but so that
works that comes out
either with a number of downsides so
first in order to train that algorithm
which is very simple
you're going to need thousands and
thousands of examples
right of different strategic numbers and
once you've trained
your algorithm because the actual
algorithm was embedded
in the neural network it does generalize
to never sing before digits right so
it's actually it's actually learning the
algorithm it's not just
learning i'm just not memorizing the
data but the thing is
because the embedding of an algorithm
the embedding of a discrete structure in
the continuous space
is not the same thing as the original
discrete object
there are glitches your diploma network
unless
something you could have found via
program synthesis for instance it's not
going to be correct
one percent of the time it's going to be
it's going to be correct you know
95 percent of the time in in much the
same way that if you try to
encode a very discrete object via the
fourier transform it's not going to be
correct so it's
100 times it's going to be an
approximation and around
sharp angles it's actually going to be
wrong and very importantly and this is
really like the
algorithm that you've you know
painstakingly embedded into your uh
deep learning model via exposure to data
does
only it does not generalize very well it
only does local generalization meaning
that
if you train it with three to multiply
three digit numbers and then you send it
a five digit number is it going to work
no absolutely not
and not only is it not going to work but
you could not in fact
few short fine tune your algorithm to
learn to handle
five dg seven digit and so on if you
want to fine tune your algorithm you're
gonna need
thousands maybe millions uh of examples
right so it's it's all uh local
generalization
and lastly it's it's super inefficient
like i think we can
uh or agree with this that
multiplication is is not
like it's not um a clever use of
an lstm it's you're you're burning tons
of resources for something that is
actually super easy
and you can compare that like since we
were talking about pros and cons of deep
learning you can compare that to what
you could get
with the program synthesis engine like i
don't want to compare to what you could
get with the human written algorithm
because kind of the point of deep
learning is that it enables you develop
programs that you could not
otherwise write by hand so the right
point of comparison is actually what you
could do
with deep learning versus what you could
do with discrete
program synthesis based on discrete
search and the dsl
and if you were to use uh program
synthesis to solve the
the the multiplication uh problem so you
would find a solution
uh even a very engine that has just like
uh maybe you know
a plus operation maybe a loop and it's
dsl it's going to find it
it can find it with a handful of
examples you're not going to need
thousands of examples like in a
different case you're going to need
maybe
five and the program you get out of it
it's going to be exact
because it is the exact discrete
algorithm it is not
a continuous ambiguous so it does not
have glitches it it outputs the correct
answer it will be lightweight so it will
be very efficient you know unlocked and
like the lscm or transformer model
and crucially it's gonna generalize so
if you develop it
only from three digit numbers maybe
there will be something inside it that
will hard code the assumption that
they're dealing with strategic numbers
but even if that's the case
you can take it and automatically learn
a
a generalized form of it if you if you
just start giving it to seven digit
numbers
very easily because it's just modifying
in probably a couple lines of code
so it is capable of strong
generalization so here you start seeing
how
for a problem that's fundamentally a
discrete algorithmic reasoning problem
discrete search is the correct answer
deep learning
it's possible it works but with
extremely stark
limitations right it's very hard to
train it you need tons of data
the resulting embedding because it's not
it's not discrete we'll have glitches
it's not going to work one percent of
time it's going to be pretend it's
only going to be capable of local
generalization right
because again like the
there is a huge difference in
representational flexibility
between your very simple discrete
algorithm
and some kind of a very complex high
dimensional company something on it
right and and then there's also the
efficiency consideration so clearly
for if you're dealing and the reverse is
also true right like if you're dealing
with a problem that's a
fundamentally perception problem where
you have data points
that fit on a nice and smooth manifold
then deep learning is actually the right
answer and if you tried to
to to train a discrete
a program to to develop in via via
program synthesis
an actual algorithm to classify mnist
digits for instance
everything i i i just said would be true
but in reverse
your program would be brittle the deep
learning model would be robust
and so on so there are really problems
where deep learning is pretty ideas
great fits problems where it's a
terrible idea like try sorting a list
with a deep learning model
can it be done yes actually it can but
with all these caveats
applying it is possible to sort a list
of deep learning
with some hacky inductive priors and
probably memorizing most of the training
data and
there's it's not a binary is it you said
yourself there's lots of problems that
fall
in the middle where there is a semi
continuous structure and some regularity
but it's still a discrete problem
and you're saying in that situation we
should still use program search but
maybe we can use deep learning
maybe something about the shape of the
manifold even though it's
semi-continuous could actually tell us
about how to do that program search more
efficiently
but it seems to me that if there are
problems out there let's say adding
numbers up in gbt3
when i when i read the stuff that you've
been talking about here it seems obvious
to me
why are people not picking up on this i
think you know most people are not
necessarily paying a lot of attention
to the nature of deep learning why it
works why it doesn't work
i also think you know the people like
there are basically two categories of
people they
are like lay people and they are people
with deep expertise
and the big problem we have here is that
the people with a lot of expertise
are gonna be a lot of the time driven by
motivated thinking right because the
you know like i do they work in the
field of deep learning and so they're
going to have this vested
interest in deep learning being you know
potentially more powerful more general
at the entries i think if you want to
think clearly
the primary obstacle is motivated
thinking
it's it's fighting against what you
want to be true so i tend to have super
boring
opinions in that sense because i i do my
best to try to forget kind of what i
would like the world to be in
my best interest and try to look at as
it really is and that will tend to
actually diminish
the importance of my own work so yeah
but you know i've been doing like
deep planning for almost a decade of
course i would i would want it to be
like this uh
incredible world-changing thing that
leads to human-level intelligence right
off the bat that would be that would be
awesome that would be amazing and
it would be right uh in the middle of it
but that's not
that's not actually what's going on you
said you
tend to be what was the word uh not not
controversial ideas or something because
you try to stick to the way
the world is rather than the way you
want the world to be
but we we just had yannick produce an
interesting video about how
if you think that machine learning
models essentially attempt to do the
same thing right i mean they're not
human beings they don't really have
wants per se they're just modeling
reality as it is
it turns out reality itself really
annoys
a lot of people like they just don't
like reality and they don't like the way
the world is and they wish it was
something different
and that infects like every mode of
their thinking actually yeah no
absolutely
most people you know and that's that's
true for me as well i i'm honestly not
saying
i'm an exceptionalist i'm trying uh to
do my best to resist
this this trend but i have no exception
most people
have opinions not because they they've
seen
evidence in support of the opinion but
because it's in their
interest for this opinion to be true or
they just want it to be true i guess one
example is you know
where we are mentioning gbt3 and so on
and proponents of gpt3
i was actually super excited when i
initially saw the claim
that the pre-trained language model
could perform future generalization i
thought
that that's that's super fascinating i
was excited like i'm always super
excited if i hear about something that's
really challenging uh my my initial kind
of
mental model of how the world works you
know it's like
a few years back and there was this
claim that an insurance was measured and
going faster than the speed of flights i
mean that's that's
that's exciting right that's like new
physics you want it uh
to be true at least you want to get to
the bottom of it and then it turned out
to be a measurement error right so
that's that's that's disappointing so i
think it should be distributed it's kind
of it's kind of the same for me i really
wanted it to be something
something novel and that would really
challenge what i thought to be true
about deep learning models
and i regret to say that everything i've
seen
close has actually confirmed in my view
that basically deeply models
they can learn to embed algorithms given
sufficient
exposure to data but they cannot really
like few shots
synthesize novel algorithms that
represent a pattern they haven't seen a
triangle which is why by the way gpt 3
is entirely ineffective on arc for
instance
and that's that's kind of sad
to me i kind of regret it uh because it
means i haven't actually learned
uh anything uh from it it hasn't
expanded
um my view of the world which is which
is too bad like i wish it did
i wish it did um so yeah so in the case
of gpd what's really going on is that
the model has been exposed to
you know many patterns you could call
them algorithms for instance in many
different contexts
and so it has memorized its patterns and
now it's able to take these patterns and
apply it and apply them to new data and
measure the same way
the multiplication algorithm we are
talking about because it's an actual
algorithm
it can process new digits it's not just
memorizing the digits in the training
it's an actual algorithm in the same way
gpd3 contains tons
of small algorithms like that but the
model is not synthesizing these
algorithms on the fly
they're in the model already right and
if you try
to apply gp3 to something for which a
new algorithm
would would need to be produced like in
octaz for instance it is just completely
ineffective it seems to all build up
what you're saying because there is this
strong generalization versus local
generalization
and then you make a case that in order
to do strong generalization we need
maybe something like program synthesis
approach so like deep learning can't
necessarily get us there in most
problems
and you make an interesting case that
something like
graph isomorphism search could play
a core role in that could you
like briefly connect all of these terms
together
of the case you're you're making there
because it's super interesting
so going back to it uh tim was saying
it's
rarely the case that you have problems
that
are fully interpolative or fully
discrete there are definitely such
problems
in fact most perception problems are
almost entirely interpretive and
most programs the kind of program that
humans right there they're
largely like discrete non-interpreted
but most tasks
actually are best solved via a
combination of both
and actually believe that's true uh for
the way uh humans
uh think you know there's type one
thinking and type two thinking
i i strongly believe that almost every
thought you have
and everything you do with your mind is
not
one or the other it's uh it's a
combination
of both that type one and type two
already enmeshed and meshed uh
into each other in everything you think
and everything you do
um like for instance perception it's
it's that looks like something like
instant so very much the solar flare
continuous interpolative thing in fact
there's a lot of reasoning
that's embedded into into perception and
the reverse is true for instance if you
look at
a mathematician for instance proving a
theorem but what they're writing down
on the sheet of paper is really step by
step discrete reasoning type thing
but it is very much guided by high level
intuition which is very much
interpolated they know where they are
going
without having to derive the exact
sequence of steps
to get there so they have this like a
high-level kind of view kind of like you
know
if you're driving you have to make
discrete decisions because you are
driving on network
frauds right but if you have a
gps for instance you can kind of see the
direction in which you are going which
is interpolating if you're talking about
direction you're talking about distances
you're talking about geometric spaces
and everything in the human mind kind of
follows
this model of type 1 and type 2 thinking
at the same time if you go back to first
principles
intelligence is about abstraction so
intelligent ceremonies about
the ability to face the future
given things you've seen in the past
and the way you do that is yeah
abstraction you extract
from the past some some construct
maybe it's a template maybe it's an
algorithm that will actually
be effective in terms of explaining the
future and that's what makes
makes it abstract is that it can handle
multiple instances of some kind of thing
which that thing is an abstraction right
and and
it's if it's abstract enough it can
actually handle instances you've never
seen before
right it does generalization power and
all abstraction is born from analogy
like abstraction starts when you make an
analogy between two things
like you say hey time is like a river if
you want to get philosophical or
something but
in general you can just say this apple
it looks similar to this other apple so
there is such a thing as the concept of
an apple for instance
and the path that is shared between the
two things that you are
relating to each other the subject of
the analogy that
that's the part that can be said to be
abstract that is the part that will help
you
make sense of the future like you
encounter a third apple in the future
you know it's an apple
because you don't even need to relate
this to the airports you've memorized
you just need to
you just need to read it to the
templates the abstract template
information
that you've formed by from exposure to
different kinds of approaches in the
past
um and if you think about what's what's
an analogy really like highly
fundamentally it's
uh a way to compare two things to each
other and there are only really two ways
to compare things um you can
you can basically ask um how similar are
they in terms of distance like you can
say
implicitly there's you're looking at the
space of points
there's a distance between two parts
that's that's the type one a sub
analogy that leads to type 1
abstractions
which leads to a type 1 thinking right
so a type 1 energy is like your things
you say
to what degree they're similar to each
other so you rate them by distance you
so implicitly it means you put your
things on in a geometric space
right um and the type one abstraction is
going to be a template
it's like you're gonna have clusters of
things so you can take the average and
say
everything that is within a certain
distance of that template belongs to
this category
that's that's type one attraction it's
very much the way deep learning models
work and and then you and then you start
having perception and intuition
on top of that which is very much type
one thinking and the other way you can
compare two things
is the discrete way right that is it you
can say these two things
are exactly the same they have exactly
the same structure or maybe
the structure of this thing is a subset
of the structure of this bigger thing so
discrete
topology grounded comparison so you have
the geometry grounded comparison it's
all about distances
and and templates and then you have the
topology grounded way of comparing
things that's all about
exact comparison of finding a
subgraph isomorphisms so in in the first
case
your objects are very much points in
geometric spaces so
they are vectors and deep learning is
always a great fit for this sort of
style and in the second case your
objects
are going to be graphs right and you're
and you're really looking at the
structure of these graphs and
substructure and so on
and you're doing always you're doing
exact uh comparisons
and in in practice um most thinking is
actually
kind of some some combination of these
two atoms
right of these two poles uh you're
you're very rarely
just gonna say yeah this airport is
exactly this close
to my tablet of an airport so it's an
apple you're gonna have basically layers
upon layers
of thinking and some of them are going
to be intuitive some of them are going
to be
more about you know comparing structures
and so on what what you're saying is
really interesting right because you
invoke the kaleidoscope hypothesis
in your paper and the idea there is that
a tiny bit of information just like in a
kaleidoscope
could be represented widely across
experienced space so you say that
intelligence is literally
having some kind of sensitivity to
abstract analogies
so the intelligence is about being able
to face
the future unknown future given your
past experience
and that fundamentally requires the
future to share some commonalities with
the past
and that's that's the the idea of the
kaleidoscope of quality is that
the universe and our lives are made of
lots of repeated atoms of structure
and in fact if you look at the source
there are very few things that are that
are unique that are kind of like
the the grains of sand that at the
origin of all the different kinds of
moving patterns you can see in the
kaleidoscope
right so the kind of like intrinsic
structure contained in universe is very
small
but it is repeated in all kinds of
variants right
and um the idea is that if you see two
things in the universe
that look similar to each other or that
share some commonalities a sub graph
maybe
it fundamentally means that they come
from the same thing
and that thing is going to be is going
to be an abstraction it's going to be
one of these
grains of sand in your in your
collective scope or grains of glass
actually
and intelligence is all about reverse
engineering
the universe to get back to this source
of intrinsic complexity in the universe
to get back to these
abstractions i think the heart of this
conversation goes back thousands of
years because what we're talking about
right now is a lot of say
platonism right which is that there are
these ideal abstract structures and of
course they they really thought of them
as actually existing
in some universe but you know even if
they they don't exist
in some reality they at least exist in
concept and
it strikes at the heart of this duality
that's always been a very
it's been one of the central mystery
really of a lot of human thinking which
is
particle versus wave you know discrete
versus continuous
abstract versus the real versus the
messy and you know
i think you pointed out you definitely
pointed this out in this call but i
think also in some of your papers that
in your view you know let's say the
ultimate solution or whatever of
creating artificial intelligence or
synthetic intelligence or whatever is a
is a hybrid system
that can do both of these types of
reasoning maybe in kind of multiple
layers
and you know i'm kind of curious where
is the state of the art now with
actually implementing hybrid systems you
know something like
i don't know is it capsule networks is
it the topological
neural networks that we talked about
where where lies the direction of some
type of a hybrid system
that in a unified way is capable of
doing
both of these modes of of reasoning if
you will
yeah that's a great question so um this
is definitely an active field of
research but
i think the most promising direction
right now is going to be
discrete search very much so a system
that is discrete search centric that has
a dsl and so on and that's one of the
it's basically just foreign but with
it is getting lots of help from the
learning models
and there are two ways in which you can
incorporate this you know
type one sort of thinking into a
phenomenal type to centralized system
so one way is so basically you want
to apply apply deep learning to
any sort of of data sets where you have
an abundance
of data and your data is interpolated
one example would be
being able to use the plain models to
generate a sort of like perception
dsl that you're discrete uh search
process can build upon so let's look at
arced
arc tasks for instance a human that is
looking at artists the very first
layer through which they're approaching
the arc task is by applying
basically perception primitives uh to
the grade they're looking at
they are not actually analyzing the grid
in a in a discrete way like cell by cell
object by object they're they're
approaching it holistically like what do
they see
and these outputs can discrete concepts
and then you can start you can start
applying discrete reasoning to them so
generating the dsl
and by the way the reason it's possible
is because humans
have access to tons of visual data and
and these different frames
share lots of commonalities right so it
is it is an interpretative space where
declining is relevant
intuition perception and the other way
which is
is much more difficult and much much
more self-working
is basically being able to provide
guidance
to the discrete search process basically
because even though
one single program so learning one sql
program for instance one arc task is not
a good fit for deploying model at
all because you only have a handful of
examples
to learn from and the the program is
super discrete
it's not really easily embeddable in
this movement
however here's the thing the space of
all possible programs for instance the
space of all possible arc tasks and all
possible programs that's so about us
is actually very likely going to be
interpolative
at least to some extent and so you can
imagine
a deep learning model that has enough
experience
with with these problems and and the
algorithmic solutions that it can it can
start providing
directions to the search to the
discretionary system so
um basically you you're you're you're in
a kind of like you have
yeah you have like layers of um of
learning
the lowest layer is going to be
perceptive it's going to be learned
across
many different tasks and many different
environments it's going to be type
type one then you you're gonna have the
context
specific on the fly problem solving
system that's very much going to be type
and the reason is going to be possible
and efficient is because it's going to
be guided
by this upper layer which is going to be
type 1
which is also going to be trained from a
very very long experience across many
different problems and tasks
and it is able to do interpolation
between different tasks so can i
um challenge you a little bit maybe
because you say
maybe you know all of these problems and
what humans do
is a bit of an interpol like an
interpolation between the
interpolative systems and the discrete
systems and
i see that going for you know something
like an arc task or
or if you really write code but if you
really come
to let's say let's say the highest
levels of human intelligence which to me
seems to be navigating social situations
which is is is ultimately like is super
complex
and i can imagine something like the
graph
structure you're referring to being
let's say i come into a room and i see
the
graphs as you know what kind of social
dynamics exist in this room you know
this is the father of this person
and that person's kind of angry at me
and so i need to
you know do something and my question is
how often is that really
a dis like how often can you really map
this
in a discrete way to another graph isn't
isn't every situation going to be a
little bit different
even in terms of its graph structure and
you know even if in an arc task a line
is just like
a little bit squiggled any program
synthesis approach
would have a hard time with it i feel or
do you think or do you think i'm
misunderstanding something here like
how how discrete is really discrete
that's that's the purpose
of abstraction the person of abstraction
is to
erase the irrelevant differences
between different instances of the thing
and focus on what
on the commonalities that matter right
so like
if the squiggle in your line is not
relevant then the proper abstraction for
a line
should abstract it away i was going to
pick up on that because your main point
basically
is that program based abstraction is
more powerful
than geometric based abstraction because
topology is robust to small
perturbations but it's more than that it
comes back to these analogies
right so we actually have functions and
abstractions
in our mind that as you say will take
away
all of the relevant differences but
focus on what's salient and what's
generalizable
yeah exactly so in in the big sense do
you think the
type 1 and type 2 reasoning are
really different or is there also a
continuum between them
like you say we need we need hybrid
systems but
is there something right yeah because
they're both
they're both in the brain they're both
on the same neurons like is there a
continuum
so right so yes and no i do believe they
are they are very
qualitatively different these are the
the two poles of cognition
but there are you know most most things
we do with our mind
are combination of both that doesn't
mean it's it lies somewhere in between
it means it's a direct combination of
one pole with the other kind of like
what i described
with with the arc solver with three
layers
with two layers that are type one and
one layer in the middle it's type two
but in very much the same way that you
can
embed discrete programs in a smooth
manifold
you can also do the reverse and when you
meaning
you can basically encode an
approximation of a geometric space using
discrete constructs in fact
if you've done any cell of linear
algebra on a computer that's exactly
what you're doing you're actually
manipulating ones and zeros
but somehow somehow you're able to have
vectors of
seemingly continuous numbers you can
compute the distance between two vectors
and so
all of this is an approximation that's
actually grounded in discrete programs
so you can you can actually kind of
merge the two together
it's not necessarily always a good idea
in particular i think it's
often not a good idea to try to embed an
overly complex or overly
discrete program in in a continuous
space as i was
mentioning earlier the reverse is
actually usually
way more tractable and by the way my i
think this is something that
that came up before in in our
conversation but my kind of
subjective totally not backed by any
evidence opinion of how the brain
works is that fundamentally it's doing
tar point on type 2
using a discrete system because it's
actually much easier
to do to do type 1 via an approximation
of geometric space it's included in a
district structure than it is to do to
the derivative
yeah and if i can um if i just for the
benefit of the reader the listeners if i
can
give some other examples you know for
example in in mixed integer optimization
it's often the case that you take that
problem and instead of having these
discrete values you project it into a
continuous space
do a continuous optimization and then as
you get sort of close to a good
optimization
you discretize it back over into the
discrete variables
you know to to kind of you know flesh
out
the most optimal path within that
discrete space or an example two is the
gamma function
you know which is a continuous
generalization of the factorial
right and it kind of provides some cool
and interesting behavior in between
those
those poles that show up very clearly on
the graph as these
discrete points and this is this bizarre
duality between the continuous and the
discrete that we see like throughout the
universe and it's
kind of one of the strangest things we
have to deal with
yeah exactly i just wonder what some of
the transformers folks must be saying
now because max welling we had him on
and
folks have um done topological
applications using transformers or using
graph neural networks and
the the alpha fold the thing from deep
mind that was
looking at graph isomorphisms right it
was looking at different types of
equivariance
in topological space is it a naive thing
to say that we could
make it continuous or are we on a hiding
to nothing
right so i guess i guess the question is
is there like one
approach that's going to end up being
universal and it's it's
like can you actually scale deep
learning to handle arbitrary discrete
problems it's kind of it's kind of a
question
and the answer is uh no actually like by
by
construction due to the very nature of
of
what deep learning is it's like
parametric continuous parametric models
and in fact smooth because they they're
differentiable characteristic on descent
that is never actually uh going to be a
good fit for most
discrete programs so and and the reverse
is true as well
i don't think so you have basically two
engines that you can use to learn powers
you have quite understand and you have
discrete search
and i think the reverse is also true
that this great search is not going to
be
this universal approach that's going to
beat everything i i truly believe that
the ais of the future will be truly
hybrid in the sense that they will have
these two engines
inside them they will be able to require
this they will be able to do this quick
search
right and then and then they will use
that appropriately
you said by the way in your measure of
intelligence paper that there are three
types of
priors right low level sensory motor
priors and
meta learning priors that's the
interesting one i think that's what
intelligence is and high level knowledge
and then we get over to the arc
challenge and and as you said in your
presentation last year
the two winning folks on that kaggle
challenge one was doing a genetic
algorithm over a dsl
so doing what you're talking about a
kind of program search and actually the
the winner who
got about 20 accuracy and that was that
was just
yeah that was um just doing a brute
force you know selecting combinations of
of operations on this dsl
so this absolutely fascinates me so at
the moment that seems like a horrific
solution but clearly no one could do
anything
using deep learning so but but this is
what you're advocating for so you're
saying for these discrete problems
get get a dsl now all the stuff you're
talking about presumably they haven't
done yet you're saying
well software engineering the beauty of
software engineering is
being able to modularize things into
building blocks in fact
i love citing this thing actually from
patrice simhart but he said
the reason why software engineering is
so good is if i ask you
how long will it take you to build the
game of tetris
you will say not long at all and if you
look at the number of state spaces in
tetris it's it's huge
but the reason you'll be confident to
build it in a couple of weeks is because
you know that you can modularize it into
into blocks you can't say the same for
deep learning right but
they don't appear to have done that on
the arc challenge yet
yeah so the the solutions we've seen on
the oxygen so far have been incredibly
incredibly primitive and so it's it's
actually
quite interesting that you can get to
twenty percent uh it's not it's very
primitive solutions i think you can even
with today's technology you can go much
further
like the what i was describing before
about learning a dsl that is perceptive
and then guiding discrete program search
yeah intuition about program space this
is already something that you can try
today so there's one approach
that i was very excited about and that i
thought was it's very cool and i really
like
it's it's called dreamcoder by dr kevin
ellis
and and folks um so check it out if you
if you haven't seen it
it's very good i think that they're
trying to try to arc now
but it's generally like it's this kind
of like hybrid
deep learning program synthesis uh
engine and i think that's really
to me that that is the sort of direction
that is the most promising
today so you have a paper that's fairly
long
on it's called on the measure of
intelligence and you make the case that
intelligence is something like the
efficiency
with which we transform prior
information and experience into task
solutions
as as you have said before and in that
same paper the arc challenge is
presented so you know a naive reader
like me
assumes there is some connection between
you know what you say about intelligence
and solving this arc challenge so mike
my question is
if tomorrow you know a new team comes
and gives you
a solution you evaluate it it gets
whatever 95
correct it solves the arc challenge is
it
immediately intelligent or like what
would you
ask of that system for for you to say
yes that's intelligent or it's it's
intelligent is is high
or something like this so you you you
would be able to make
that that conclusion if and only if
arc was a was a perfect benchmark but
it's not
it's actually very much flawed so if you
solve arc are you
are you intelligent um
well no because arc is potentially
flowed that's that's the thing so
the thing you need to to really
understand about arc is that it's not
kind of the end state of this
intelligence benchmark
it is very much a work in progress and
there will be new iterations
especially as we learn more about the
flows and by the way
so last year we ran a kaggle challenge
on arc
and we learned a ton not necessarily a
ton about program synthesis approaches
although
there were some cool stuff with cellular
automata and so on but mostly we learned
about the flowers of arc so there will
be
future editions and so on so i will tell
you this um
if you solve the specific test set of
arc
as it exists today you're not
necessarily intelligent because it is
not perfect because it has its flaws
but if more generally speaking you give
me a system
that is such that any new arc task
i throw at it like i can i can make some
new ones tomorrow for instance i give
them to your system if it's always
solving them
i will say yeah it's looking like you've
got a system that that's got you know
pretty close to human level
fluid uh intelligence this is one of the
things that um
look and i like the paper a lot i think
i think it serves as a really good
um you know foundation for us to think
differently
about how to build intelligence but but
i have some some issues with it too as
well and one of them is this sort of
necessity that it requires kind of white
box
analysis of things in order to figure
out whether or not they're intelligent
because for example suppose time travel
is actually possible
and you know somebody like 100 years
from now looks back on your arc thing
and writes an algorithm that
that solves all all them in there
because it actually knows about them
already and then ships it back into the
past and we enter it into the
competition
and no matter what new arc thing you
throw at it it sort of does well
and you say well yeah you know this
thing's like kind of intelligent
but but we'd be wrong because in the
sense in the paper it's actually just
encoded you know prior knowledge from
the future so we have to
we always have to kind of be able to
look into the box right in order to
evaluate
intelligence in the way that you define
in the paper and so my question is
one isn't that a bit of a undesirable
feature
and two do you have any hopes for a more
black box
measure of intelligence so basically the
fundamental issue is that
if intelligence is this conversion ratio
then computing it requires knowing where
you start
from and you don't really have a way
around it so
the the thing to keep in mind is that
the under measure of integration stuff
is not so much meant to provide like a
solar flux
golden measure tape to measure anyone's
intelligence or anything
intelligence it is uh more meant as a
sort of
cognitive device to help you think
about what the actual challenges are uh
to help you kind of kind of reframe
ai because they think that they've been
pretty deep and long-standing
conceptual misunderstandings and that is
really being that's been holding the
feedback
so it's very much meant as a cognitive
device
um if you if you take a step back
and you and you ask why are we even
trying to define intelligence and
measure intelligence in the first place
why
why is it useful at all i think it's
useful to the extent
that it is actionable right a good
definition
and a good measure should be actionable
so meaning it should help you
think it should help you find solutions
and
it should help you make progress in
particular a good definition is a
definition that will highlight
the the key challenges and help you
think about it and i think that's that's
what the paper does
and a good measure is emerging gives you
an actionable
feedback signal towards building the
right uh
kind of system right in the sense that
it will be capable of doing
more and so that part uh the feedback
you know is what is what arc is
trying to achieve and um the way it's
trying to control for priors and
experience
is by assuming uh a fixed set of priors
and and you're going to say you know
every every test take yours gonna have
this price
this is the core knowledge priors they
need controls for experience by only
giving you a very small number of
inputs for example and also by making
sure the tasks are sufficiently
novel and surprising that you're
unlikely to have seen
very similar instances before so now of
course it's super flawed so this is not
100 true of course but this is kind of
like the
the platinum ideol that we are trying to
get to so that for the record that's a
fascinating point to me is that you view
this more as a cognitive device to help
guide us to produce better
better intelligent agents it is not an
endpoint it's not like arc is like the
measure of intelligence
and and now all we need to do is sort of
arc this is not at all the point it's
like
it's one oh darn because i was doing
pretty well on some of the examples i
was hoping that would
mean i was intelligent but another
interesting point because keith and i
were looking at the paper again
yesterday
it's been um i've haven't properly
studied it since last year but
um we were starting to talk about an
alien that comes in from outer space and
you know
we don't know the the prize and the
experience and then
i was thinking in a way it might be a
kind of lower bound on intelligence
right because
you know if i play chess and if i beat
someone with a higher elo than me
then only really tells me that i'm
better you know as good as that person
that i just beat
and similarly this measure of
intelligence it only gives you
a reading in the situation when you know
what the conversion was
so if they are not converting anything
then you don't know
and another interesting byproduct of
this
is the more experienced you get the less
intelligent you get
so i would um i would push back against
that last claim
that the the measure of intelligence as
i define it is dependent on
how much experience you have um because
the amount of initial expense you have
does not actually change the conversion
ratio
if you if you measure it via the right
task
so you might need so if if you have a
fixed uh set of tasks then yes
it does affect it but if you if you're
able to renew your sort of task and and
come up with stars that are orthogonal
to the experiment that you have then
it's not it's not going to actually
affect the definition so
but yeah you're you're definitely right
that if you take a pure black box
approach and all you're looking at like
the only thing you can really measure
is the behavior of a system
and unless you know how that behavior is
achieved
you can't really tell immediately how
much
intelligence was was involved in
producing this video if you look at an
insect
they're capable of super complex
behavior are they are they crazy
intelligent when actually you know
probably not
and the way you can really tell is by
putting these systems
out of their conform zone getting them
to face
novel situations and see how they adapt
and that's the measure
of intelligence it's adaptability the
ability to
to deal with novel and unknown
situations but in order
to give your system a novel and unknown
situation you need to have
this white box understanding of what wet
it already knows the box
yeah and that that's that's not really
something you can you can work on
so can i ask about the the
generalization difficulty because i sort
of had
some difficulty intuitively with some of
let's say it's limiting cases so for
example
you know the algorithmic complexity is
highest
let's just suppose we're dealing with
problems tasks where we have
whatever sets of integers mapped to 0 1
values you know the
the algorithmic complexity will be
greatest when that's just a random
mapping
like i just assigned 0 and 1 randomly to
every single
integer and if i go to look at that
generalization difficulty
it's going to be super high because the
the length of the program
for any set is basically going to need
to be you'd have to encode the entire
set as a hash table
right so how does like this measure
account for or help us
avoid problems where we're confusing
generalization difficulty with just
increasing random you know randomness
well i mean increasing randomness
is a part of generalization difficulty
right
generalization is really the ability to
deal with the stuff you don't know about
the stuff you don't expect
the stuff you haven't seen before and
randomness is is a part of it but you're
right that
if you just add randomness to a system
you're increasing the generalization
difficulty
but you're not increasing it in a very
interesting way
right because uh you are increasing it
in a way that's gonna
orthogonal to an integration system's
ability to deal with it
right the best you can do is modify the
system to be more robust
to to very much randomness because
that's not
super interesting what's really
interesting to is to test the system's
sensitivity to subtle analogies it's to
make the system face novel and
unexpected situations that are actually
derived from the past but in interesting
ways
right not just random ways you've run
this kaggle challenge on
on arc and you know we we know from
systems such as
alphago and so on that bootstrapping
intelligent like bootstrapping ai
systems can be very valuable
like playing them against each other and
so on and um
also we know that something like markets
can be very
efficient and valuable and i
imagine a system where you'd have
agents creating arc tasks and other
agents
solving arc tasks and they're going some
kind of money
around and so on and this could be kind
of a powerful
engine for research teams to research
anything
like this and you know given that you
have i don't know how much but you do
have the backing of
of google with a bit of capital in hand
do you could you imagine could you
imagine there you know being
uh a push for this kind of thing or or
is it as of now
an intellectual curiosity yeah um
yeah so i i i don't have you know
that much backing you from google around
this this kind of project
um but yeah so it would be super
interesting to have this
kind of two-part system where one part
is generating the task and one part is
learning to
to solve them and you could get them to
do some kind of curriculum optimization
like the task generator network would
not just generating you know
no it would not just be trying to
generate tasks that look like our tasks
it will be trying to generate tasks that
correspond to level of generalization
difficulty and complexity that is
right below the limits of the student
system that's trying to sort them
kind of like you know the way a teacher
would provide
exercises that are solvable but
challenging they shouldn't be they
shouldn't be easy they shouldn't be
impossible they should be soluble
children because that's how you get the
most growth so it's actually a system
that's described at the very end
of the paper on the measure of
intelligence and i think one thing i
point out in the paper
is kind of like the the pitfall you
should avoid
falling into is that this system is
circular
all right and the complexity you're
going to see in your task
it needs to come from somewhere right
uh it's like on the conservation of
complexity
so the the system this two-part system
needs to have
a source of intrinsic complexity needs
to be grounded
in the real world and one way we can
achieve that grounding
and i've been thinking about it is i
think we should you know
like our tasks are as they are today
they are made by me
and this is not a good setup because
it's going to be biased
it's going to be very battlenecked uh as
well i think we should start
crowdsourcing our task there should
definitely be you know a filtering
system so that we make sure that we're
only keeping our paths that are
interesting that are not too easy that
are not difficult
and that are only grounded in in core
knowledge requires
but if we have like this string of novel
arctis that contain
intrinsic complexity and novel
information because they come from the
real world they come from human brains
um that have experienced the real world
and
you use that as a way to ground your
task generator
then you you're starting to get a very
interesting three-part system
right so i would i would love to to
actually get that started to actually uh
uh produce uh a v2 of arc as soon as
possible that would include you know
10x4 tasks
and that that would be a crowdsourced
and maybe something that would take the
form of a continuous challenge
where you where you have an api where
you can draw a new arc task and every
time you draw a task it's actually a
different one
because you have so many of them uh game
of fire that'll make a fun game yeah
on a mobile app there are actually a few
people who've created because arc is is
open source and totally free license
there are a few people who have created
mobile apps where users solve our tasks
and apparently it's popular so
there's also the other angle you
mentioned in the paper which was which
is pretty fascinating you're talking
about it almost right now which is that
okay let's let's start thinking about
how to map
arc performance to psychometric
you know classic kind of psychometric
test are there any
efforts that you're aware of underway
right now to do that are you involved in
okay so there are two groups any etas
yeah etas i'm not sure
so we did we did a workshop at triple ai
the other day and there were
two presentations about efforts that
teams of people
so there are people who do new
psychology and they are using arc
in very interesting ways so there's a
group at nyu and there's a group at mit
and there and there yeah so they are
using arc for new psychology experiments
and it's it's super cool amazing
um i want to switch over a little bit
because of course you know other than
the measuring of intelligence
you are also famous for a small library
you wrote once in a while
called keras and i i wish i wish i wrote
it
and and then that was that
no yeah it's been very much an ongoing
project for the past six years
it was because i remember you know the
days of tensorflow 1
and and theano and things like this
and and keras was just i think so
helpful to a lot of people because
it just easified all of this you know
graph construction
what not and and so on it just made it
accessible to so many people
and now with the development of you know
things like
pi torch and tensorflow 2 it almost
seems like
keras is it has been kind of absorbed by
tensorflow 2
right there is tf.keras and now i think
the newest apis are even sort of
vanishing that a little bit
do you do you see uh keras going away do
you see it
changing where do you see it where do
you see keras going
yeah so going away definitely not i mean
we have
we have more users than than ever before
and we're still growing very nicely
both inside google like more and more
teams at google are moving away from
transfer one and adopting keras and and
outside google as well
it's it's it's a big market out there
and there's definitely room for multiple
frameworks
um evolving absolutely i mean keras is
constantly evolving
but evolving with continuity like if you
look at cameras from 2016 or 2015 you
look at class now
you recognize is it the same thing and
it's the same api
and yet it's actually a very different
and
much much bigger set of features and
things you can do with it
uh so evolving definitely and um
there are so several so you
i think you asked you know about yeah
like uh keras is getting kind of merged
into tensorflow does it mean it's it's
like fading away
so definitely not so merging with
tensorflow was
a good idea because it starts enabling
a spectrum of workflows from the very
high level
like psychic language to the very low
level number like
and everything uh in between in the
early days
because keras had to interact with
multiple backends if you had a backend
interface
it means you had this kind of like a
barrier where
as long as you use the krc as everything
was super simple
it was psychically enlarged so very easy
very proactive
very fast but if you wanted more
customization at some point you would
hit that back end
barrier and and you add reverse to
tensorflow base or theano based workflow
that was low level but when where you
couldn't really leverage cars
effectively by removing the backend
thing
and just saying the flow together in one
spectrum
then you get really this progressive
disclosure of complexity
when you can start out with a very high
level thing
but then if you need to customize your
training step if you have an api for
that
and you you can just mix and match
seamlessly
the low level tensorflow stuff with the
high level character
and that way you can achieve any you can
work with chaos and tesla at the level
of abstraction that you want
a very very easy high level of very very
low level
full flexibility it's history up to you
i'm gonna point out the temptation here
to analogize
connecting type one with type two uh
reason yeah why not
wait i was just about to do that at
least the francois
has great form for this because not only
does he talk about having powerful
and useful interfaces and abstractions
in deep learning he's
he's been playing this game in you know
in in the library world for quite some
time but
um i wanted to touch on this quickly we
had a couple of people in our community
um asking you about keras actually and
uh robert lange and
and i ivan finno said that
apparently thiano has returned with jax
and xla underneath and he wants to know
are there any plans to edit there's a
keras back end and robert lange also
says you know
just jacks on its own would you add that
as a back end we've also had a couple of
questions about pytorch as well is there
anything on the roadmap for that okay so
let's talk about jacks i think jax is an
awesome project and the developers have
really done
a very very interesting and very good
job with it and lots of people
i like jax actually so that said
adoption is not super high i think
google is probably the company where
it's the most adapted where you will
find the most users and even then
it's like a tiny tiny tiny fraction of
total average any message at google
but i think as a project it's it's a
beautiful project
it's elegant it's powerful it's great so
would that would i like to
add jack's back end to carrots or bite
watch back into us
so i want to say we've really moved away
from this lag
interface back end kind of model so
precisely for the for the reason i was
describing because you want to achieve
this spectrum of workflows without
having this cliff
where you go you you fall from the high
level
down to the low level we don't want
clips we don't because cliffs creates
silos
of users where you have the high level
users you want a gradient yeah you want
the
gradient spectrum exactly so that said i
think it would be super cool to have
a sort of like re-implementation of the
keras api
on top of jacks that would also achieve
this grading
and that will still follow the keras api
spec it would still be the same thing
but on top of jacks that said so i would
i would love to see something like this
this is also very low priority for us
because we have
the the actual current keras which which
we need to work on which has lots of
users
so we don't really have time to do this
but in theory would it be cool yeah sure
i would i would love to see something
like this so
if i had tons of free time i would i
would probably build it but
in practice fantastic we got another
question from giovanni actually he says
what does francois think of dr kenneth
stanley's book on the myth of the
objective
are you familiar with kenneth stanley's
work about the tyranny of objectives and
open-endedness
so i'm vaguely familiar with the name
i'm not really familiar with the book oh
okay
well sorry no not to worry but it it's
um
ken has been a huge inspiration for me
and and he he talks a lot about
um objectives leading to deception
so sometimes following um an objective
monotonically
sends you in the wrong direction and his
solution to that is either quality
diversity or more recently
open-endedness which is that
if you have an infinitude of objectives
in in a sense the system has no
objective and you can
you know also with diversity
preservation you can overcome deceptive
search spaces but yeah
you might have heard of the poet
algorithm which he which he was involved
in yeah absolutely no i'm aware
and so when it comes to your your
description of the problem with
objectives i i completely
agree with that one one thing i
mentioned in the paper it's like the
the shortcut rule which is that if you
try to achieve
one thing one objective you're gonna
you're gonna achieve it but the thing is
you're gonna take every shortcut
along the way for things that were not
actually incorporated
in your objective and this leads to
systems that are not actually doing what
you wanted them to do
like for instance we built chess playing
systems
because we hoped that a system that
could play chess would have to
be able to feature reasoning uh book
learning
creativity and so on it turns out it
just plays chess
that's what it does the same is true
with challenges on kaggle but the
winning systems they just
optimize for the leaderboard ranking and
they achieve it
but they achieve it at the expense of
everything
else that you might care about the
system like is the code base readable
no is it computationally efficient no
it's it's actually terrible you could
never put it in production
is it explainable no and so on yeah so
it's like if you if you optimize for
something you get it
but you take shortcuts yeah it's exactly
and that's very much what kenneth says
as well
i love what you said about shortcuts you
said in your newest presentation that if
you optimize for a specific metric then
you'll take shortcuts on every other
dimension not captured by your metric
and you said in a machine learning
context that's similar to overfitting
right because
on task specific skills you actually
lose generalization if you get good at a
particular task so it's completely
orthogonal to what you want
i know you're very well known for your
skepticism of the intelligence explosion
and
what what i love about your conception
of intelligence is that you think of it
as
as a system or as a process you say that
intelligence is
embodied right so you have a brain in a
body acting in an environment and um
in in in that context it makes sense
that you would think that there are
environmental
kind of rate limiting steps to any kind
of super intelligence right but
um i spoke to someone the other day who
is of the other persuasion shall we say
and this person was um saying well what
if you had a super super smart bunch of
scientists i know you said in in your
rebuttal
that if you look at the iq of a
scientist who is
leslie richard feynman for example it's
the same iq as a mediocre scientist
turns out that iq only helps up to about
125 and then it stops helping you
but these people would say oh well you
know what if what if every single
scientist was an einstein and
intelligence is just making better
decisions
they would consistently make better
decisions and science would accelerate
a chimp doesn't understand how good a
human is so
how would we understand what a super
intelligent person would do you know
they'd invent nanotech they'd upload
themselves into the matrix they'd do all
of this stuff
and somehow they would miraculously
overcome do you know what i mean how
would you respond to that yeah
if every scientist was super intelligent
in human terms that would in fact
accelerate science but it would not
really like accelerate science in a in a
linear fashion
and very much not in an exponential
fashion so
i i guess the main conceptual
differences i have with
these folks is that they tend to credit
everything humans can do
to the human brain and and they have
this vision of intelligence
as you know a brand in a jar kind of
thing and if you tweak the brain and
gets more intelligent
and intelligence is directly expressed
as
power uh if you're more intelligent if
you have a hierarchy you can do more
things you can solve more problems and
so on
and in particular you can build a better
brain and and by the way there
is not really any practical evidence
that's
true but i view intelligence here more
as this holistic
thing that okay you have the brain but
actually the brain
is in a body which gives it access to a
certain set of
actions it can do instead of set up a
perception primitives
and this body is an environment which
gives it access to
a set of experiences instead of problems
it can solve and to a very large extent
you know
the brain is just it's not so much a
problem-solving algorithm
like a problem-solving descending as it
is a big spawn
and you put it in environment it will
absorb experiences from that environment
and um one thing that's super important
to understand if you're an issue if you
really think deeply about intelligence
is that
most of our expressed intelligence does
not come from here it is
externalized intelligence so
externalized intelligence can be
can be many thing um if i look up uh
something online that's externalized
intelligence google is part of my brain
if i
write a python script to test some idea
that's externalizing it
my laptop is part of my cognition
and so on but it's actually it goes much
further than that most of our cognition
is crystallized the crystallized output
of someone someone else's thinking and
the process through which we get access
to all these accumulated outputs
of people's thinking is civilization
right and
like 99 of the things you think
are the behaviors you you hacked
babies you execute you did not invent
them
you did not solve the underlying problem
yourself
you're just copying a solution
you've seen like where in the middle of
the pandemic you're probably washing
your hands after you went outside and
that's very smart behavior
but did you invent it did you come up
with that no
actually other people came up with that
you did not also
come up with the infrastructure that
enables you to do it in the first place
and so and this is true you know for
even the the most
intimate of your thoughts you're
thinking with
words that you did not invent you're
concepts uh that you did not invent or
that you did not derive
from your own experience they they
really come from
other people from this accumulation of
past generations
and if you want to enhance
the expressed intelligence of people
then this is actually the system you
need to to tweak and
improve not the human brain but
civilization
right in a way that seems like a
contradiction
because you're talking about the
externalization of knowledge
not intelligence so by your own
definition doesn't that
isn't that the opposite of intelligence
that that's a great point
so i'm i'm relating express intelligence
so i was
specifically saying express intelligence
as opposed to fluid intelligence and
what expressed intelligence
means in this context is something very
different from what we we talk about in
the measure of intelligence it means
intelligent behavior right and in
particular i think the
the ability to solve problems that you
encounter as an individual
typically when you solve a problem as an
individual you're actually using a
solution you've
found somewhere else it is there are not
that many problems that
as an individual you solve from scratch
in your own lifetime but here's the
thing is that if you're able to actually
solve something novel
yourself you have the ability to write
about it you have the ability to
communicate it
and then the next generation can can
benefit from it so let me dispose a
kind of a counter argument to this
though suppose
know suppose you're reading a novel
about uh i don't know kind of
planet of of the apes or something which
was which is a planet that had a life
form similar to ours but with a
significantly lower
lower iq right and and you know a human
being shows up there one day and and
these things start writing about this
hey this weird you know
alien just showed up here and and we
captured it you know we ran some tests
on it
and we figured out it's really
intelligent you know it's much more
intelligent than
than any of us are and and we're worried
what's going to happen when you know 100
of them show up
instead of just this initial explorer
and some other
other of these guys were like ah don't
worry about it you know they've they've
got two legs and
two arms like us and most of what they
are is kind of outside of their brain
so you know i'm not i'm not really
worried about it
we would be reading that with
trepidation right because we know that
when this more intelligent species with
more fluid intelligence
more externalized intelligence better
technology all this kind of stuff shows
up
those guys are going to get wiped out
and it's actually happened like
many times throughout human history not
that humans were more
fluid intelligent showed up and killed
off you know other people
but humans that had more externalized
intelligence or more
you know represented intelligence and
technology certainly showed up and
dominated absolutely
you you're seeing it yourself that you
it has happened
in history it was not fundamentally
about one
people having smarter brains but one
people having
higher technology but that is not
something that is attributable
to to intelligence itself right there's
a connection there if you did have a
group of species or whatever
that was much more intelligent they will
have advanced technologically much
faster and further
in any given amount of time all else
being equal right
it depends on many factors and that's
kind of my point is that
is your brain a factor yes absolutely it
is
but there are other factors like we are
just talking about
the development of technology so in that
case the the critical factor was not
the brain but this superstructure in
particular communication
and environmental constraints around it
the direction in which a
civilization develops is a direct
function of the specific
challenges it it encounters that come
from its environment it comes from this
it's surrounding enemies and so on and
techno
technology core development advances the
fastest
when you have a civilization that are
dealing with
very harsh challenges but that are not
quite large enough to work them out
um because that's what forces them to to
develop as fast as they can
survival based so this is actually a
very good example where
the critical factor was the super
structure that guided the ribbon
civilization was not actually the brain
but of course yeah if if one is smaller
than civilization we
will advance faster but the
my point is that there are many factors
and that by tweaking one factor
the brain if the brain stops beating the
bottleneck then
immediately some other factor will be
the bottleneck there are
uh civilization civilizations that have
not actually advanced
very much at all because they simply did
not face any challenges
and did they have worse brains no
actually they had exactly
the same brain uh but somehow the the
outcome was different because something
else uh then the brain turned out to be
demonic like
a lack of environmental change for
instance right
i'm fascinated by scale and bottlenecks
and systems actually except i work in a
large corporation
and when you have role fragmentation and
lots of different businesses and lots of
different
organizational structures some people
might decide
to structure themselves based on data
domain or based on
organization or based on something else
and you can think of it topologically
and i think human society is very
similar to this
and i'm not sure whether you know
evolution would lead itself to one
particular topology but
the environmental structures and the
ways that we organize ourselves can
create
incredible bottlenecks and that seems to
be where the real
interesting stuff goes on rather than
the individuals and
i think you would agree with that
francois yeah absolutely if
if you take two companies and in one
company the average iq is like 15 points
higher
but it has a terrible organizational
structure and table incentives and the
promo
process is super broken or something and
that company is actually going to
perform worse
than the more progressive innovation
encouraging company
and it has a very nice organizational
structure and where people are actually
more mediocre and maybe maybe they have
on average 15 points
less in in iq but they're actually going
to do a better job because they have the
better superstructure
yeah it's fascinating that the problem
is in in most corporations you can't
actually
design the information architecture to
be more efficient
because everything is so decentralized
and fractionated
you can only do it in pockets and if you
try and fix something in one part of the
organization everyone else will say well
my requirements are different
i'm not going to wait for you i'm going
to do it my own way and it's actually a
really really difficult thing to do well
to sum up the the whole like
intelligence explosion thing the the
point is really that
it's a system you have to look at
holistically to get it
key and just by tweaking one factor
which is
the intelligence of an individual human
brain then what this means is this
factor starts being the bottleneck
but that means some other factor in the
system because there are there's an
infinitive factor that work
will become the bond and by just
focusing on one factor you're not going
to
actually lift all the boots yeah i
and i i actually agree with you however
you know i do want to say i think we
just don't know i think
both sides of the intelligence quote
unquote explosion really can't say for
certain
that it will or will not pose you know a
mortal threat to humanity like i think
we have to accept that it's at least a
risk factor
right and we have to be very careful
about you know
in the future when we start embodying
you know
if we find general intelligence we need
to be cautious if we come up with
something that looks like general
intelligence
there is absolutely some risk potential
around it however you know i've never
seen
anything coming anywhere close to that
in fact the
the systems that we have today they
feature almost no
intelligence whatsoever so i think it's
it's it's a bit early to stop
anything and even if we get into that
conversation i think francois would say
that intelligence must be specialized
right because of the no free lunch
theorem if if you define intelligence as
your ability to solve problems
then yeah it's going to be specific to a
scope
of parts a kind of problems
and like yeah what what the new french
theorem is saying is basically
if you want to learn something from data
you have to make assumptions
about it uh which is why you know a
covenant for instance is a great fit for
image data it's not really a great fit
for natural language processing
and because it makes different
assumptions about the structure it
doesn't give me a lot of comfort though
because i'm i'm fairly certain that
whatever the first
agi that gets created it's going to be
highly specialized for killing other
people
because it's going to be a military you
know secret project probably that finds
it
you know it's um i i don't know but what
i know is that
right now we don't have anything coming
close to agi
it's probably going to be actually a
system that
just displays you ads like if like
if you know if we see where the most
money is right now the the first agi is
probably just going to
like write not only display but write
the perfect ad for you
on the fly yeah like you should it knows
what you ate and
you know i know you're joking but i
actually think an
animosity or something that's highly
unlucky
because of the shortcode of the story
because of the shortcut rule
i don't think and a general intelligence
is going to be created by military
it's not going to be created by a system
that's trying to show you ads
because these are specific goals and so
if you try to optimize those specific
goals you're going to end up with a very
specialized system
in order to build a general intelligence
you need to be optimizing for
generality itself so it's going to come
from
if it if it comes from the applied
either it's going to come from the
academic side where
you have researchers who are actually
optimizing for generality itself
security as angle or if it's come from
the apply side it's going to come from
people who have problems where they have
to deal with extreme
novelty and certainty and practice
unpredictability so it's not going to be
ads it's not going to be the meteor
um i don't know what it's going to be
one of the things that interested me
about kenneth stanley was that he you
know he says the reason we can't
monotonically optimize on objectives is
because of deception which means
sometimes you need to get a lot worse
before you get better
his original conception was quality
diversity which basically means
if if you optimize for novelty that's
something that you can optimize on
monotonically
and also if you look at evolution where
there is a cacophony of problems and
solutions
you know divergently being generated
then
as an information accumulator you can
optimize on that monotonically and your
conception of
of intelligence is generality and that
also appears to be a monotonic
increase throughout advancing levels of
of intelligence so i think that's quite
interesting
anyway um france virtually this has been
my dream come true to
have you on the show thank you so much
it really means a lot to us and yeah i
appreciate it
thank you yeah thanks for having me on
the podcast it's it's really my pleasure
this was this was super fun
thanks a lot and thank you for caris by
the way thank you i'm glad it's useful
we're going to jump straight into the
post show
analysis okay well i'm going to mention
you you did really well tim that
that trickle sweat that this was running
down your face the whole time
yeah not very noticeable so i think you
can you can relax you did
that was fun that was really i think it
went pretty well yeah yeah it was it was
a dream come true
i was actually i was very pleasantly
kind of interested
in how he he framed you know the measure
of intelligence paper like look it's not
really about the measure per se
it's just that this is this is a
cognitive framework a cognitive tool for
thinking about
where to go and a guidepost for building
more generalizable or more general
intelligences
say like that i totally totally agree to
and it's quite
you know quite a fascinating goal which
is like here's a framework to help us
think more in the direction we need to
be thinking
yeah and it's so surprising that
like the arc challenge is at like 20
solved only because
you know he self admits that it's it's
flawed
right because he like he makes the tasks
and you know there's only finitely many
and
and you know you kind of you see the
kind of tasks he makes you know on
in the public set you would think that
not someone would come up with an
intelligent thing but someone would
come up with like a smart set of
shortcuts
to like solve that sucker right but it's
still at
20 i don't know whether that's due to
just you know
not too many people investigating it um
or whether it's really actually a hard
problem
and if it is our problem you know
well it's fascinating too because if he
if he achieves what he wanted which was
getting it more outsourced right like
getting all the intelligent people all
around the world contributing
to ark problems and refining them over
time i think actually that
community project would help the core
knowledge people
in that line of research and figuring
out okay what
what is a catalog of all the core
knowledge right it's
again back in school we used to call
these prime thoughts because we would
we would play these brain teasers all
the time and we realized that
there were patterns right like well this
brain teaser requires the concept of
coloring like with a red black tree
where you add an additional variable
that kind of lets you
solve the problem and if we could really
have a nice catalog
of here's all the core knowledge here's
all the like problem solving techniques
i think that would be
really powerful i mean well we kind of
had that so this woman elizabeth spell
key
she came up with about six core
knowledge systems right and and that and
the arc challenge uses four of them so
objectness and intuitive physics one
agentness to elementary geometry and
topology three
numbers counting quantitative
comparisons so the two that weren't in
there are places
and social partners now the thing is i
think we may discover new ones
well yeah maybe we will but i'm
surprised that we did as well as 20
because if you think about it imagine if
you just guessed
the classification on imagenet when
you've got a thousand classes
20 would be amazing wouldn't it and we
we've got a similar
amount of diversity of tasks on arc
right and
what's interesting as well is that all
of those different
tasks that have been created by francois
they all tie
back to just four priors right which
means
i don't know whether it's uniformly
distributed but
20 seems really good for just guessing
ops on a dsl
yeah there's there's two things so first
i would have thought that if someone
if someone came up with something that
solves more than five percent it's going
to be like immediately at 95
like just because they've they've sort
of cracked the problem
and and then you know there might be a
few outliers but you know
if i i would guess that's kind of a task
that if you hit the correct solution
it's going to be like boom you're you're
there and that's not which is
surprising and the other thing is i
i don't i don't feel it's surprising
that there's so few
priors what i do think is that the space
of these priors is still
way too large like so if if you just
think about something like object
because in in these arc tasks there are
i feel so many more priors
than uh just the core knowledge things
because
so one of them is like you have to you
have like
this thing and then you have this thing
and the solution is like it
goes boop right it go it like bounces
but this is like
yeah but but like the fact that we
recognize like this is a wall or
something but
there is no there there's no no prior to
says like a wall needs to be straight
the wall could be
like any you know any old any shape at
all
and the fact that this is much more
core knowledge right like in you know we
we build stuff out of straight walls
and i think i think i agree with you
which is i think i think what you're
getting at correct me if i'm wrong but
it's that
the way in which the core knowledge is
kind of specified right now is vague
right there's a vagueness to it and i
think if we actually
start to try and codify that more in
some type of a mathematical language
tim i think it's going to expand like
the scope of that we're going to end up
with more
core knowledge concepts really than than
just six we'll need to make them finer
grained and i'm really excited
you know to see that develop because
this has been for me
a long wonder right which is what are
the in in a rigorously defined way
what are these core concepts these core
bits of knowledge that make human
cognition
so powerful yeah and there's also
because yannick made the point about
brittleness
right even in topological space you
still have brittleness but but the
solution was to
create powerful abstractions right but
how would that work with the priors
because if you think about it
you can recombine many of the priors to
come up with powerful abstractions and
you might find that it doesn't actually
filter down to
to that many but the question is how
many things are there
remember when we spoke to waleed suburb
he was talking about
he's got them somewhere in a powerpoint
deck he just wouldn't give them to us
but you know part of
part of why why i agree with yannick
that their finer grain concepts are more
important i think probably stems from a
lot of the computer science
um education that i had were when we
were devising algorithms to do one thing
or another
you get these little hints that kind of
like clever bits of
core knowledge that was used to solve
this problem like when you study
quicksort and it's like you know what
like i'm just gonna randomly choose an
element well random selection is kind of
a bit of core knowledge
and then i'm just gonna partition by
that and then repeat you know or things
like
i don't know how to balance this tree
the way it is but if i color stuff
like add in red black nodes i can now
overlay a computation that
you know so there's all these little
bits that you know that's what's
fascinating about computer programming
is it
is it really strikes at the heart of
this cognition and this
core knowledge and how to written you
have to do it rigorously right you can't
just vaguely go oh you know just kind of
sort it and merge them you got to
define like what that means and it's
fascinating dynamic programming yeah
i'm always i'm always a bit amazed by
people who have just
kind of sort of learned programming
because
it it's it's almost like a different
world in that they'll
they'll they'll do it's like oh okay i
need to
solve this problem can i can i copy
paste this code here
and it works like 20 of the time but not
fully yeah but then on the other side of
the coin to that
um so when i was working in um
you know quantitative trading right we
had these these massive
globally integrated automated trading
systems
and i mean some of the bizarre i don't
want to call them hacks but some of the
bizarre
sort of piecewise linear equations
slash hacks whatever that actually work
in reality
you know you sit there and you look at
them and go when i first went in there
it's fresh out of academia and i started
seeing things like this is crap like i'm
gonna figure out some continuous
equation that you know
fits this piecewise linear thing and
it's going to do better nope
like it didn't do better i couldn't find
any continuous thing that did better
it's like
you know options pay off right is this
this piecewise linear thing
and and you're like oh that's that well
there should be some continuous
like thing in there like all these weird
you know
piecewise discreet like kind of hybrid
things between continuous and discrete
work and and and that's weird it was
weird to me and still weird to me
interesting but i've got to say so my
main three take homes from chalet today
i really love chalet so one intelligence
is generalization i think that's super
powerful
two his idea that deep learning
is really good for value-centric
abstraction
and because of the manifold hypothesis
lots of
natural data has some kind of manifold
which you can interpolate on
but lots of discrete problems do not
have that
right and my mind was thinking well does
that mean that we can just use
because it's because of sgd you can't
even learn the manifold even if it did
exist but he's saying that it doesn't
exist for discrete problems
the manifold might be there or it might
only be there in parts so that was
interesting
and then the third thing that fascinated
me about chile is is he talks about
these systems and and bottlenecks in
systems and we shouldn't be thinking
about
individual brains we should be thinking
about the externalization of knowledge
yeah and and the way he the way he
described this um
what what he thinks like a hybrid system
should look like
which is sort of you have a perception
layer and then
a a discrete search layer and then on
top of that
kind of another fuzzy layer that guides
the search that can be deep learning
again
and i think we're we're like halfway
there on the top with
the top very much looks like alpha zero
right
which is kind of a discrete search that
is guided by
neural networks and the bottom layer we
have too because that's just
our you know regular neural networks i i
think we
we have a big trouble in how to connect
the two
in a in a single unified way such that
we can learn them
right because the best we can do right
now is
is right we can we can plug a
pre-trained
network onto alpha zero or something
like this but we can't really
we don't really have it figured out yet
how to connect the all this stuff
a good example of that is the the neural
turing machines like how it's so hard to
to optimize them right and i think and
not only do we need these kind of
three components that that nicely
integrate and are optimizable
we have to be able to modularize and
componentize
and connect multiple instances of those
things together
in some you know weird topological
network to really achieve like kind of
the capsule network
kind of vision where each of the
capsules is maybe one of these units
and then they're a part of this it's
like a fractal you know kind of these
fractal layers of
those pieces i don't know whether i was
misunderstanding you before yanny but
with the alpha zero thing my conception
is that has
been quite hard coded so you're you're
searching through
let's say a bunch of deep learning
models and the way you search is quite
opinionated what chalet is talking about
is have a very basic dsl
and in that topological space you you
just search
and and you start to modularize and you
start to create functions and
abstractions and you have
from a software engineering point of
view you start to build a library of
functions that have been written in code
that do certain things
right and that's that's different isn't
it to alpha zero
well the the alpha zero is made yes
specifically to to search over actions
in
in some kind of rl space yeah i mean
what what he describes is certainly much
more abstract in that you
you search over applications of
the dsl and the dsl itself is not
is like a perceptive dsl that
in in itself is described by these lower
level neural networks but
i mean in s i i just it that just came
to my mind when he described the system
i'm like oh the the top part looks very
much like
you know alpha zero because that's
essentially neural network
guided search is something we we already
already do though yeah i
i i think i'm not sure i think just
the reality is even a bit more fuzzy but
because
what you do as a as a human there's also
some part of
hierarchical system to it in that you
can you can do
this but you can do it hierarchically
right you can
you you can be like okay i'm gonna right
i have to solve
you know i have this high layer search
and then each of the search
things goes through maybe a fuzzy thing
but then
you you again search at to solve the sub
problem
and um there is also you can do it at
will too by the way
like you can you can scan an image and
you get this type one that sort of finds
a bunch of objects and then you do this
type two thinking where you start
reasoning about those
and in your mind you can kind of zoom in
on one let me like zoom in on that tree
and now like
now i've got the bark the pieces of the
bark as objects and bugs and reason
about so you have this ability
to transcend the process and tune in and
move it around
yeah this this self like the that's the
whole consciousness aspect right that's
even
like apart from intelligence you have
the ability to to introspect
the whole thing and that probably is a
big part of intelligence
i mean i guess you could have
intelligence without consciousness but
you know there is an argument to be made
that the fact that you can introspect
your own processes contributes in big
part
to the furthering of intelligence
yeah i would separate consciousness and
intelligence but
it the thing that hit me the most on his
newest presentation
was when he said intelligence is
literally sensitivity to abstract
analogies
so we were talking about the
kaleidoscope the main thing here with
intelligence is that
there is so much repetition in the
universe
right but it's repetition in this funny
way where it's it's sort of
fuzzy repetition like yeah sure the
solar system kind of resembles
galaxies kind of resembles you know but
but then there are these little
weird differences these asymmetries and
you know
like the universe is a fascinating place
i mean and
i don't know something yeah right that's
not when you say you you have to make
analogies which is
i can i can absolutely see you know this
and me
i think my question was formulated a bit
dumb where i said you know if the line
is squiggly
what i more meant is that you know in
in that case it's not a line it's a
squiggly line
and the same with the social situations
you know that is like okay
that person over there kind of doesn't
like me but then in the next social
situation it's kind of a person that
doesn't like you
and has a gun or or something like this
i
i almost feel like or a group of people
or a group of people
sure they are similar in some way but
it's never
the exact same thing so this reasoning
by analogy does work but you always do
your little modifications on top
specific to the situation and i'm sure
there's a place in this framework
for this but it's it's just again it's
it's like
a lot more complex than yeah i think
that's what he called
i think that's abstraction at least that
you know that was prior to today
my my concept of extraction was similar
to that which it's removing the in
insignificant details so you're able
you're you're able to take
whatever you know some you know object
thing situation doesn't matter
and kind of strip away all the stuff
that doesn't matter for whatever your
purpose is that's abstraction and you
know i think one of the weird things
is that and this is kind of the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics right is that
abstracting actually produces things
that are
useful you know that abstraction i think
the fact that abstraction
helps with generalization is a very not
well understood
kind of mystery in a sense like why
should abstraction
help generalize but it does like in the
real world
that's what happens though the yet
abstraction
in though abstraction has to be somehow
specific to what
what you want to do like like right an
apple is an
apple only if you know you're looking
for food or non-food but
when it comes and it's a sphere if you
want to shoot it out of out of a
potato can exactly but when it comes to
you know separating
fruit by ripeness then it's not when
apple is an apple then all of a sudden
this apple
has much more in common with this orange
right so
even the way how you abstract it's not
like
it's not like we can just you know plug
in our resnet 50
and then boom we get an embedding vector
and that's our abstraction but
how you abstract is also
incredibly specific to what you want to
do
yeah and that's what yeah and i agree
with saba that this is an empirical
question
right you know like he's kind of like
these concepts or whatever it's an
empirical question and chalet's
i think the pr the art project if it
ever becomes this crowd-sourced thing
is going to give us lots of data to
start thinking about this empirically
and it's going to be really fascinating
i mean this needs to be
like this is a this is a prime
blockchain
project because you can you can probably
like you can probably even
zero you can zero knowledge prove that
you can solve
uh a given set of arc problems
right you can probably create zero
knowledge so you wouldn't even have to
show your solution and if there you know
people would put up arc problems
and they you know if you want to try
them
you will have to put up some money and
if you can solve it
you know the the creator of the
challenge
gives you some money or something like
this like this this could be
fascinating maybe you could do you know
homomorphic like uh arc right where like
you don't even
you somehow like you're saying you can
just prove you can solve the problem
without ever you having seen the problem
but just an encryption of it
yeah yeah normally homomorphic
encryption comes
after blockchain in the same sentence
yeah what else can we get in there ten
weeks so we got blockchain homomorphic
encryption what else
what can we throw in there bitcoin can't
we just say people should have to pay
through bitcoin
if if they if somebody wins a challenge
on hark we'll get our own token of it
artcoin oh god hold on i gotta get that
domain right now
i want to know by the way so the whole
point of the arc diversity of tasks
for developer aware generalization which
means the developer
could not have conceived of the task but
if all of the tasks are representing
for human priors then
how is that developer aware of
generalization because the developer
would be aware of all of those price
of the priors right but not not of the
the task right that's the the control
is the contr like that's what he said
you have to know the start
of where your your white box analyzing
from and this the start is not clean
slate
but the start here is these four priors
so it's it's kind of the diff
between you give the developer those
four priors
what can the developer come up with just
from that
right yeah because i think i think
there's a lot of information leakage
there and
you implicitly said the same thing
because you said once you solve it
you know once you solve some of them
you've solved all of them okay
artcoin.com is available for the
it's but it's it's a premium domain so
it's 300 bucks should we get it
because it has coin in it i guess
we need to figure figure out something
cooler
like no art coin okay
i don't care enough to grab it right
anyway we should draw this to a closed
latest adjustment but yeah thank you
very much for listening we published yep
thank you it's been it's been emotional
we've recently reached 10k subscribers
actually so uh yeah
thank you very much we're still going to
continue the show
now that we've had chileo oh yeah
i thought this was the end i thought we
were going to cap it with sure i mean to
be honest
we might as well just stop now
anyway see you thanks thanks bye
i really hope you've enjoyed the episode
today remember to like
comment and subscribe we love reading
your comments
and we'll see you back next week